Đông chỉ thương trực bán biệt thư trên cầm tụi nhấn mạnh ý nghĩa, tâm quan trọng của các giãn
trong điểm được rao cho văn phòng trung đàn. Đông chỉ khai qua tên mạnh nha ông vẫn đề
cần tập trung, đó là đối với các giãn thuộc phạm vi đầu tư câu khẩn cấp.
Các nhóm vẫn đề thuộc mấy giãn đầu tư công đặc biệt và chất giận của các cơ quan
đơn vị liên quan. Đông chỉ trình cầm tụi của các cơ quan và các cơ quan đơn vị liên quan
và đặt trọng tâm thời hạn hành thành các giãn có chất giận theo dõi kìm chà, đồn đốc
khi thời không được ra hạn thông tin thần chỉ đạo của bộ chính trị và đồng chỉ tổ bị thư
chủ tính nước tổ lâm. Già xuất, ám dụng các cơ chế đặc thù đặt có mà đảm
nguyên tắc chỉ tử phó lợn theo quy đệ. Phóan thành đúng tiến đồ các tiêu chỉ về chất
lợn đặc biệt, nhấn mạnh yêu cầu rất cao là tuyệt lối không về sẻ ra thất thoát
lãn phí tư cơ. Nhấn mạnh đơn quan trọng của công tác vận hành vào tăng đàn cộng
hạn thần Việt Nam sau khi đi vào hạn đầu, đông chỉ trình cầm tố liệu ý yêu cầu về thành lập bộ phận
vận hành, thu thập, bố chỉ sắp sếp mà quan trứng bầy mà tốn tay liệu, viện vật,
tuyển trọng của những lực trước lượng cao, trên khai đào tạo, bối giữa chuyến một sâu,
đáp ứng điều kiến khi bảo tăng đi vào hạn đầu, thường trực bán bị thư đến gỷ văn phòng
trung đàn ra xuất, có phục kìp thời các khó khăn vướng mắc trong khóa trình trên khai các giãn,
rắn chắc nghiệp đơn vị trù trí, hối hợp, đông đốc thường suyên bảo cáo kết quả văn tiếng độ hành tôn về ban
sỉ đạo xe dựng các công trình trong điểm. Các bộ ngành trụ động hỗ trợ văn phòng trung đàn thảo gỷ khó khăn,
bà đàn tiếng độ, sớm hòn thành giữa án đưa vào xử dụng đúng thử hạn.